episodio 42
[Música]
bienvenidos a otro episodio del podcast
l geteccu en el cual hemos venido
platicando sobre temas de la diversidad
sexual para este episodio vamos a
regresar al tema del travestismo y digo
regresar porque los primeros recordarán
ya habíamos abordado las identidades las
orientaciones con los testimonios de
personas correspondientes al grupo que
se le estaba dando visibilidad y el
travestismo fue previamente abordado
pero desde una postura desde una forma
de expresión del género es una expresión
como arte como tú proyectas lo tienes en
la cabeza como tú empoderadas a través
de este personaje pero en esta ocasión
vamos a platicar del travestismo pero
desde otra perspectiva
también existe el travestismo por una
identidad es decir la persona se
traviste utilizar ropa más alineada al
género que siente en su interior esto es
de manera
al vocacional en un escenario
determinado o por algún otro factor que
esté impidiendo que inicie su proceso de
transición o simplemente también es
posible que no inicie ese proceso por
gusto propio o sea porque no desea
alinear su cuerpo o empezar con las
hormonas etcétera pero vamos a tener una
invitada que nos va a poder compartir su
testimonio y sus razones del por qué
ella no ha comenzado con este proceso
transitorio así que vamos a comenzar
[Música]
el travestismo o trans best ismo es una
expresión de género e identidad de
género en la que una persona se expresa
a través de la vivencia personal
esto puede involucrar la modificación de
la apariencia con la función corporal a
través de medios farmacológicos
quirúrgicos o de otra índole siempre que
ellos sea libremente escogido también
incluye otras expresiones de género como
la vestimenta el modo de hablar y los
modales la identidad travesti tiene
diferentes connotaciones dependiendo del
contexto temporal cultural y regional a
pesar de que durante muchos años se
utilizó de modo despectivo e insultante
el colectivo trans travestis
transexuales y transgénero apropió el
concepto y lo resignificó convirtiendo
el estigma en un emblema de lucha
colectiva
la diferencia entre el travestismo y la
transexualidad es que en el primero se
expresa o se tiene la intención de
expresar una discordancia
entre el sexo de cada persona y los
roles asignados a cada género mediante
una representación a veces exagerada de
rol del género contrario mientras que en
la transexualidad existe una
discordancia real interna entre la
identidad de género propia y el sexo
biológico transgrediendo así el sistema
si es género pasando a ser una persona
transgénero
en palabras más sencillas y en
referencia a una persona transexual el
travestismo es la acción de expresarse
socialmente de una manera concordante
con la propia identidad de género y
discordante del sexo biológico
convirtiéndolo así el travestismo en una
conducta transgénero
ya vamos a pasar a la plática con
nuestra invitada para el episodio del
día de hoy
[Música]
mientras esté donde vives y cuál es tu
en este caso tu identidad de género
hola yo estoy así y romina luna tengo 26
años y vivo en la ciudad de puebla y mi
identidad de género es confuso jajaja
estoy en una es una chica trans una
persona a través de una persona que
viste de un género opuesto en
determinado tiempo determinado fecha en
solo que es como un momentáneo baja como
para algún evento o nada más por el
gusto de vestirte entonces llevas tu
vida en el rol en el que naciste pero te
vistes del rol del género contrario
perder varones no piensa el ranking es
un tipo de pedráz el trasvestismo pero
creo yo que depende la como el contexto
por ejemplo puede ser que yo inicié
atrás vestirme a mí me preguntaban de
qué te vas a operar las chichis que no
es que yo no estoy muy cómodo con mi
cuerpo
pero luego entonces
ubicas parodiando alguna vez lo viste
soy claro bueno el chico esté pagella
arámbula
a la vida a mí me gusta cantar y desde
que yo era chiquito mi yo ya que quería
ser artista y cantante y nos que
entonces lo veo a él haciendo pues lo
que nadie hacia no aparte de ser muy
bonita y cantar precioso y demás está
imitando una voz que no era la de él que
no estaba en su rango vocal que te
escuché es un timbre de voz y es
completamente diferente al de una mujer
no entonces es como que me nació esa esa
chispita y dije algo ahí ahí que puedo
yo hacer entonces empecé a dando mucho
otra vez pero yo inicié cantando como
gloria trevi igual como él lo hacía yo
conmigo y me di cuenta que también me
salían voces intuición hacía
leiva ni nada de eso si inicias y por
esa razón no empecé a vestir ya sabes
que cuando inicias pues parece está mal
mal envuelto y todo eso no la verdad es
que yo inicia así o sea 9 20 o sea no
tuve hermanas mamás trabajos a cero
youtube ver vídeos y me como una idea
pero obviamente estaba yo bien
porque estúpida no quedó nada que
trabajar con él ha recordado por favor
tengo 26 años el tren de mar 27 aunque
ya qué edad comenzó está parodiando
tiene que salió no recuerdo en qué
edición salió para ver claro que lo
ubicó a él porque fue muy icónica su
participación justo por por las voces no
que lograr imitar y e increíble todo
pero cuántos años tiene de eso que tú
vienes haciendo esta actividad como 89
años yo creo por eso que el que yo
recuerde mi voz mi timbre de voz yo creo
que como muy así
15 la voz de joe cuando intento por
ejemplo cantar una canción de alejandro
fernández o sea tengo que fingir la voz
porque realmente este es mi voz pero
entonces ya sabes no estás haciendo la
limpieza y estás detrás de mi ventana
entonces me decían como que tenía bonita
voz sino es que pero como que no me
creía capaz porque lo puedo ver como más
tangible pues cantando como rara y por
ejemplo no no nada más serán artistas
los meter o cantantes de pronto chávez
la india maría no esté
completamente conmigo
en ese programa
de hecho de hecho fíjate que un
programa que se llamaba aceite doble
de azteca y va como el mismo giro mande
me voy me invitan al casting de
presencia del ajusco pero entonces que
ya sabéis pues nunca me había ido tan
siquiera viajaba yo al centro para que
te des una idea es mucho menos nueve
llorar ciudad de méxico y en ese tiempo
mis papás como que no les encantaba la
idea de que o bueno no sé si hoy en día
les encanta pero antes no les encantaba
esa idea de que me dedicara a cantar
entonces les dije pero no no me apoyaron
y pues no fue porque entonces aquí antes
de que me vayas adelantando a tus papás
lo saben pero no lo apoyan o se lo
imaginan o saben que no lo haces para un
trabajo que es lo que yo sabe mira mi
mamá sabe hoy en día todo de mí yo como
te llevo una vida de niño bueno
o sea traigo unas dichas uñas
larguísimas de que el cabello largo y
pestañas postizas
pero bueno entonces es ella ella fue mi
primer show por ejemplo entonces digamos
que en ese entonces yo no tenía una
buena relación con ella entonces pues
como que no lo apoyaba no ya decía que
me dedicara estudiar o cosas así que se
lo que para que como pasatiempo y demás
esa era como su idea pero no me la supo
transmitir es como que la verdad me
desánimo pues dejé de hacerlo pero si
ella fue a mí a mi primer show y
llevamos de que a sus amigas lesbianas y
así es este interesante que como a veces
los padres pueden apoyar y tener amigos
pero como que en su casa les cuesta a
veces fíjate que apenas estado yo
tomando está esta plática con los ojos
muy tolerante estos somos súper open
match todos somos súper chivos pero no
sé qué hasta que realmente tienes el
problema en tu casa
a preferencia sexual los dos somos super
tolerantes por ejemplo ahorita con el
aborto porque alguien en tu casa a ver
cómo lo coma a ver al médico de acuerdo
entonces creo que realmente todos
empezamos a desarrollar conciencia hasta
que realmente lo vivimos entonces creo
también por ejemplo el mejor amigo de mi
mamá era era gay por el murió de sida
antes también esto fue como un golpe muy
fuerte para mi mamá y alimento como
muchos de esos inseguridades es que
ustedes no se quede y mira lo que te
puede pasar se sabe el amor se convirtió
en sobreprotección y en la
sobreprotección muchas veces lástima
muchas veces te cortan las alas porque
mucho me pasó de eso o bueno yo permití
como caer en el mismo sistema de
creencias que al final eran ni siquiera
de mi mamá eran de su amigo cambio bueno
pues al ser muy cercano pues lo vivió
muy mal obviamente cuando tienes algo
así en tu casa en este caso familiar
pues no esperas no tiene capaz de algo
yo pueda lastimar reír a alguien que
quieres es muy cierto es que dice si
tienes toda la razón creo que es muy
distinto tener un amigo a que tu hijo no
y justo por eso en el compás también
creo que también tuvieron el tema de mi
infancia y mi juventud como que me
acuerdo que hasta el personaje le hacían
tal cosa por esas vivencias se les
generan unas connotaciones súper
negativas del tema entonces sí tiene una
razón pero dentro de todo digamos que
hubo un apoyo para ti y diego apoyo no
era el apoyo que yo quería o el que
estaba esperando no de pronto yo estaba
esperando como en que todo fuera una
cama de rosa pues no al final la
relación o sea para que yo hoy en día
tenga una relación con mi mamá tuvieron
que pasar mil cosas muchos años salir
del closet a los 12 años gigante hoy en
día a mis 26 años estoy disfrutando la
relación con mi mamá échale cuentas
largo el proceso realmente si no están
esos cortos de ahí ya le dije ya me
senté a contarle los hombres obviamente
no justo justo estaba yo hablando hay
una niña trans que está iniciando su
transición y es cercana bueno es prima
de una amiga y justo estaba yo como me
dio la oportunidad de que platicarán y
mi familia les está apoyando de una
manera muy padre pero también hay
cuestiones donde existe una residencia y
de pronto hablando le dije te voy a
decir algo que me decían y me cagaba o
también estaba que mi hija era tranquila
todo mejora o sea mejor aquí cuando has
llorado o sea como como me doy cuenta no
sé si eso sea y elegir posiblemente
ahorita que te diga puedo mejorar me vas
a decir lo mismo en tu mente o en
palabra no sé pero te digo algo o ya mis
26 años con la vida que llevo con lo que
me ha costado con lo que he pasado con
lo que me ha levantado y además si te
puedo decir que todo mejora entonces
como como experiencia como consuelo si
hay chicos chicas que estén iniciando en
un proceso similar no nada más en
cuestión trans travesti o sea con todas
estas nuevas identidades que hay que
digo en mis tiempos no me tocaron por
ejemplo te puedo decir que todo mejora
cosas como una una lucecita al final del
camino pero hay que ser pacientes
debemos ser fuertes debemos llamarlos
amarnos a morir o sea en verdad marte
con todo lo que eres creo que esa van a
ser las mejores armas para para poder
defenderse en la vida porque cuando tú
te amas no no no permites posar pones
límites aprendes también a compartir
contigo mismo contigo misma al no
juzgarse no porque muchas veces es lo
que nos pasa al menos a mí muchas veces
decía porque a mí o sea porque no puedo
elegir algo tan básico al decir me gusta
esa vieja no porque tal ayudas es bueno
pues era como algo muy básico porque era
cuestión de gustos pero no era a mí no
me gustó no era tan fácil de elegir
entonces hoy en día en mi presente algo
que valoro mucho es la lealtad entonces
cuando yo sobre lo dicho yo no soy fiel
yo soy leal entonces hoy en día de que
valoro tanto tanto la lealtad porque
nadie puede venir a decirme que es la
lealtad cuando yo a mis 12 años y contra
toda mi familia contra el mundo o sea y
me impuse y dije yo soy esto y así las
cosas y inameh
o sea y fui contra contra todo no es
como él como el consejo que puedo dar no
se requiere mucho valor pero es lo que
se va a los que llegan porque es un
infierno vivirse aparentando ser que no
eres sabes el tema desde ya cuando una
identidad viene porque aquí a los 12
años entiendo que tú sales del closet
como niño gay o corrector y ya después
de cuántos años pasó lo de que bueno
ahora sí soy si me gustan los hombres
pero resulta que yo no soy un hombre es
que mira fíjate que es como muy con o
realmente porque mucho tiempo incluso
apenas no tiene mucho que ver que grecia
no que le escribieron que como como
lidia vas con tú con tu batalla de estar
en tu cuerpo y ella lo único que dijo
fue es que no tienes que estar en una ya
contigo misma tú no eres tu rival tú no
tienes que pelear contigo entonces es
justo eso no yo recuerdo que cuando yo
era muy niño desde el kinder me acuerdo
esté toda la vida llamado gloria trevi
toda la vida me encanta bueno
correctamente me gustaba más la atrevida
/ es la verdad a mí a mí me encantado
con el medio que la chamarra en la en la
cabeza y cantar pelo suelto y su verbal
escritorio del maestro a las villas
entonces yo desde el suicidio o sea me
acuerdo que a mí me gustaban hacer esas
cosas me acuerdo también que por ejemplo
en la primaria había un niño que me
gustaba no yo siempre lo supe pero al
final él en el lugar donde crecí y en el
tiempo también el que crecí todavía como
que la homofobia estaba como muy latente
no entonces yo ya sabía que el que me
gustara ese niño era estar mal no
entonces desde ahí te vas como
reprimenda reprimiendo reprimiendo
reprimiendo premiando y entonces ahí es
cuando realmente tienes que hacer como
este análisis porque a mí me ha costado
mucha terapia por ejemplo es
muchas la nación y demás es cuando me
topo con un terapeuta me dice como
exponiéndole en mi vida me dices que
mucho por trabajar porque es muy fácil
decir eres atrás y ya no hay que ver que
algo que todo el contexto no porque
bueno yo puedo decir no me sentía a
gusto con mi cuerpo pero entonces
necesito realmente hacer un análisis si
no me gustaba mi cuerpo o no me gustaba
lo que me estaba hacer haciendo sentir
en ese momento de mi infancia por
culparme por yo saber que estaba mal y
aún así hacerlo sin yo tener la culpa si
me explico entonces desde ahí puede
generar como un tipo de
resistencia y no a lo mejor no sobre mi
cuerpo sino simplemente a lo mejor como
mental es que está mal que un niño me
guste y desde ahí te empiezas a culpar
imagínate tú en la primaria yo en mi
caso segundo de primaria estamos
diciendo que son que siete años seis
años y realizara culparte por algo tan
fuerte que es pecado que está mal que no
sé qué es algo realmente muy fuerte
entonces hoy en día puedo decir que en
cuestión de identidad de género para mí
es complicado no está definido
completamente porque es algo de lo que
le tengo mucho respeto a ver cómo lo
decía el psicólogo es muy fácil ponerte
en falda pero realmente quién eres con
esa falda y quién eres y en esa falda
entonces me ha costado
27 años esta identidad porque ya llevo
una vida gallego amigos llevo familia o
se llevó una imagen o sea entonces no se
trata solamente de ir a ponerte chichis
sino realmente el saber que las quieres
o realmente estar 100% seguro segura de
que lo que te la tienes esa infancia es
la realidad en cuestión personal
industrial emocional y hermano lo que
menos quiero es chingar me sabe vuelve a
lo mismo
hoy en día te digo me voy me pongo mi
falda y la pongo la revista si bien
perrita me encanta porque aparte me
gusta y demás y la next a mí me gustó
mucho como soy entonces este es un poder
inmediato no el que me da pero
normalmente lo he ocupado en su mayoría
de veces para salir de noche no sé de
que en ese entonces cuando cantaba y
estaba ya en un escenario y el hecho de
transformarme y no ser yo era liberador
saber era hijo el eje es es mágico o sea
esto es no siendo tú y no porque estaba
imitando simplemente desde la desde la
caracterización desde el maquillaje ya
no eres tú ya te atreves como hacer
cosas diferentes si puedes ir que es un
empoderamiento diferente o al menos así
lo veía en su momento de noche cuando
salía yo con mis amigas a bailar cuando
de pronto se te acercan a ligar ella te
invitaron esto que ya te pagaron ya
sabes es como abogados pero qué es lo
que puede ser el día cuando te tienes
que enfrentar a los niños cuando te
tienes que enfrentar a los güeyes
borrachos de la calle a los alucino casa
a todo o no qué pasaría incluso si te
enfrentas en tu mismo trabajo o sea
imagina que estás en tu trabajo
tranquilamente una mamá local piensa que
estoy dando mal ejemplo hoy por ese mal
ejemplo hacen que me corran o sea chad
cuotas donde digo yo admiro de verdad a
las personas que ya iniciaron como yo
también encima reciente y claro
os admiro como mucho esa valentía y
demás yo en el en el ramo en el que
estoy realmente no he tenido problema en
cuestión laboral porque yo aparte de
cantar me dedico a poner uñas y hago
poquitos estilismo importante soy
estilista josie técnica no años y soy
muy perra por cierto
[Música]
[Risas]
si te lo juro que hay 26 años poniendo
uñas por ejemplo y la vez que las
trabajo bastante bien trabajo por
ejemplo en una buena zona que un pueblo
me ha costado poder trabajar en ese
lugar y además wen la en esa zona que
puedan pagar mi trabajo y demás por
ejemplo también estoy aprendiendo del
tarot lo del canto o hago venta hacen
todo podemos decir entonces que romina
es únicamente un personaje o si la
consideras tu identidad de género es
decir el travestismo tú lo experimentas
más como una identidad de género o como
una expresión de vigo espero no ofender
te con esta pregunta yo yo creo que está
bien o sea por ejemplo el mito del
tiempo de paso en el trabajo es que como
te digo el ella o sea a ver no tengo
tema mi nombre es este o sea como si tú
sientes que me voy a enojar no tengo
temas como tú me quieras llamar yo sé
quién soy o sea no tengo como ese tema
entonces dictó me dice es que si tú te
disfrazas de mujer
o sea para mí es como el entiendo que tú
lo veas así o sea no me afecta pero
sabes que esta generación de cristal
está como muy potente ahorita virtuales
quieren manejar todo con pinzas pero a
ver mi vida la vida no es así o sea la
vida no podemos ir poniendo en los
y las cosas van a cambiar
mágicamente todo llevamos por ese punto
a esta relación de cristal hay que
enseñarle a ser más fuerte no creo yo
que ahora también lo somos noventeros
pero
yo siento que el bullying de los 90s el
bullying que nos tocó a nosotros si era
un bullying en verdad fuerte o claro una
parte sabes que digo la generación de
cristales donde yo lo veo es un
resultado ahora la generación de cristal
es una generación después de nosotros y
una generación antes de nosotros por la
que empezó a protestar entonces la
generación anterior a nosotros fue donde
empezó a sacar garras y empezó como la
ley para la mujer y para no sé que el
dolor como muchas atrás empezaron con
las marchas la comunidad que ahí no sé
qué pasa nuestra generación y empieza un
poquito más de libertad tienen un
poquito más de conciencia pero nuestra
generación no tuvo los huevos de hacer
por ejemplo lo que hoy en día la
generación de cristal ha hecho porque
por ellos también se ha hecho mucha
justicia en muchas cosas entonces en la
generación de cristal son nuestros
primos son nuestros sobrinos son
nuestros hijos a los que estamos
educando y ellos están hablando a través
de nuestra crianza en nuestra educación
ellos son los que están sacando las las
cosas como son es un resultado
exactamente entonces antes de juzgar
chequen por qué están así me parece muy
interesante el tema generacional porque
en efecto como lo mencionas una
generación tiene ciertas cualidades
carece de algunas habilidades en
consecuencia da de cómo fue la
generación antes es ahora en esta
específica generación yo no creo que sea
por falta de lo que menciona suceda no
creo que sea por falta de valor no creo
que nos haya faltado valor a las
generaciones anteriores con quizá quizás
sí o sea si era un camino que tenía que
recorrer pero bueno yo pienso en la
generación de cristal lo que se viene a
sumar
como punto para volverlo factible es el
tema de las redes sociales sabes el tema
de la tecnología el tema de que los
movimientos sepan encontrar aunque estén
así lejísimos cinco pájaros aquí cinco
pájaros en eeuu sociales no era lo mismo
en nuestra generación donde aquí
protestaban diez personas y en el otro
extremo del mundo protestarán 5 entonces
es crear la tecnología es un punto
importante para que esta generación
tenga estados como que estaban de gitano
yo que se ponga el crédito de que ellos
abrió para decir creo que la tecnología
fue algo que les facilitó hacerlo y
claro pues ya digo vuelvo a lo mismo
todo es un resultado y todo va a votar
algo entonces si quieres un resultado
diferente de las cosas simplemente no y
por eso es lo que te decía al final si
tú me dices hoy en día si tú te
disfrazas a mí no me afecta es como el
viento que a lo mejor no tengas como
esta delicadeza o como esta sutileza de
poder estarte y tú estás expresando a lo
mejor con respeto y la de mejor otras
personas que son ajenas lo toman trabajo
es un pulgar falta exactamente y no lo
tiene por eso se escucha en el contexto
quieres aprender quieres saber no
entonces hay que hay que enseñar
entonces tampoco hagan como un gran show
por eso es así o sea de verdad yo no sé
a mí no me gustan las marchas a mí yo la
verdad no yo creo que se han
distorsionado mucho el motivo nunca ha
dado como mi opinión sobre esos
movimientos pero yo sí creo que son
movimientos que si se va por lo que fue
creado o sea creo que es lo que hace
quizás se distorsione el no saber
respetar a veces tú decías que estás un
tanto ajena de la comunidad del
eléctrico bien que completamente ajena
y existe algún motivo por el que no has
iniciado su transición o simplemente no
no piensa hacerla nunca no lo considera
necesario para estar a gusto contigo
misma mira te voy a decir algo que es
como de mis virtudes pero también de mis
de desventaja y la vez que soy una
persona como muy distraída sito ahorita
me estás atacando
el ego ni cuenta me voy pues a menos que
sea como muy literal que no tendrán su
despacho o sea si es como muy literal si
la cacho y entonces si me defiendo no
pero siendo la gracia es que a mí es
como católico me dices ojo todo o
sea en el contexto en el que estamos a
lo mejor de como dices así me diste
hermanas 6s
pero qué pasará si de pronto a lo mejor
voy en la calle y me gritan eso lo que
también por ejemplo no sé estoy loca que
a un niño puede aguantar todos los
pilotos horribles que tú
o sea pudo soportar que alguien llegue y
se va a hacer no sé pero lo que no
tolero son los chiflidos a cada núcleo
si me lo han hecho por ejemplo en la
calle o si he escuchado como comentarios
o de pronto están una bolita de huellas
del baño que nos queda saber ese tipo de
cosas pero vuelvo a lo mismo o sea qué
pasaría y de pronto me hice un los
albañil o sea yo pasaría así y me
encabrona me doy la vuelta y le digo sus
madres al final el tema transfóbica o a
lo mejor si me ven como un cabrón y una
música o algo así por ejemplo a lo que
me expongo para qué para qué exponerme o
sea para qué compartir de esa energía
que tienen ellos y para ellos es
gracioso ofender a alguien por un
distintivo pues yo creo que las
apariencias están hablando realmente
entonces a mí la verdad estar acá enorme
y la verdad es que a mí no me no me
afectaría como tal ni me detendría yo a
decirles cosas o no me he detenido a
decir cosas la estima enojado porque sí
enojado muchas veces e incluso hace como
un año
la compañía dio mal super y me había
enfermado kovic entonces me afectó un
tanto los pulmones y demás y el mi
recuperación me dejaron este no me
dejaron o sea me tiene lo que está para
mucho los precios entonces ese día esté
aquí hay una plasta exhiba más de
cristal vamos a placer que estará este
trabajo y gente pues lleva yo con
chamarro votado se acompasa así vaya
hasta traer chongo en el cosa 0 entonces
menso éste ya me voy yo para la casa
porque no salió sea independiente nuevo
con mi mamá me vaya para mi casa y veo
un chico que limpia los parabrisas y me
empieza a hablar de después de
caminar normal
y veo que se cruce la calle se echa a
correr así como a media cuadra para
esperarme x me doy cuenta y luego es que
hizo fue atravesar me en la calle
entonces como que se sacó de onda y
empieza a actuar yo pensando que me está
hecho planteamiento
entonces sólo seguí caminando derecho y
a continuación veo que viene otro chavo
hacia mí que está haciendo como que está
revisando la basura me di cuenta que
estaba chiflando que cuarta ex plan do
el otro le estaba haciendo señas les
dije no es a mí entonces no se me
quedaba viendo pero atrás de él no había
un es un bar ahí salió alguien y cuando
establece alguien que venía atrás de mí
o sea muy ajeno como que iba no sé al 8
no sé el otro se atraviesa y empiezan a
chiflar los dos y justo en la otra
esquina que me aparecen tres güey igual
de la misma pinta como que estaban
limpiando los paraguas entonces ahí hay
una formación guadalajara cuando me doy
cuenta porque ya sabes el instinto
muchas veces te avisa tu ángel guardián
nos dio
entonces
sentí la necesidad de entrar a la tienda
cuando voy a entrar a la tienda los tres
se me ponen enfrente y no me dejaban
pasar entonces se empiezan a reír y solo
le dije como permiso y los a 20 o sea me
metí a la tienda entonces
sólo le dije a las chavas que estaban
trabajando a prepotear aquí me están
siguiendo 5 güeyes entonces la charla o
lo que sí que no sé que instale en
espiar y 3 estaban afuera de la tienda y
los otros dos uno estaba en los estaban
en en las
apuestas
entonces como vieron que empezaron a ver
las chavas y demás lo que se empezaron a
alejar y demás pero imagínate que
hubiera hecho si yo lo hubiera aumentado
la madre tuve o sea que hubiera pasado y
de volver a mentar la madre mejor
alguien a alguien de ellos o lo sé
alguna otra cosa usaba lo mismo como
para que me expongo lo más sensato que
puede haber hecho es como buscar un
lugar seguro no arriesgarme
y el hombre en lo mínimo a lo mejor
versión la pu pisa ahora imagínate si no
sabe entonces este tipo de cuestiones y
me han pasado pero creo que la se ha
afrontado bastante bien también conozco
casos de personas que no han tenido como
suerte no y donde les han hecho cosas o
cosas es la verdad entonces es plaza tu
sentido a gente y van a hacer algo por
por tu expresión de estas aves que de
hecho este chavo el de los
limpiaparabrisas
ya me había visto como dos o tres veces
y siempre me hacía derecho o cosas y
sabes pero yo de hecho te digo algo
tengo como un vago recuerdo y creo que
este niño iba en la misma primaria donde
yo estudiaba
porque se me hace muy conocido entonces
dije no sea por eso digo que ya usando
no sin volver ha querido asaltar yo lo
hubieran hecho en ese mismo momento
no me hubieran dejado entrar a la tienda
o veraniegos a me hubiera visitado algo
sabes no pero esto no va a ser a chingar
si usted realmente era como el chingar o
meterme miedo entonces al final pues
nunca bache la mirada nunca
nunca lo deje de moverme hacia donde yo
tenía aquí no entonces a lo mejor si
estaban esperando que me regresara para
que yo demostrara miedo y a lo mejor se
más secarán entre todos o hacer un mal
chiste o algo así pues tampoco lo
consiguieron sino explicó pero eso no
quiere decir que también te vas exponer
a algo eso es justo lo que yo o sea lo
que siempre pienso cuando veo a las
chicas trans saben social como cómo será
su día a día como será tener que usar
nos el transporte público y pues sí
evidentemente él cree en la misoginia y
aparte la homofobia que
entiendo completamente el feminismo si
lo apoyo si no apoyo la violencia si
apoyó la libertad tiene empoderamiento
queda el feminismo eso sí pero
si no anda bien sabes o sea
al final qué es lo que pasa cuando
generas más violencia ante violencia
pues va a terminar mal o sea realmente
es algo que no o desde mi punto de vista
no ni siquiera le haces caso no o sea es
algo que pasa a mal recuerdo porque
ahorita por ejemplo las marchas que
violentaban y demás todos tienen el
recuerdo de que las mujeres pegaron
pintaron pero nadie habla del contexto
del por qué se hizo eso sabes entonces
solamente está recordando que los lo que
creen anclado en la mente es que el
feminismo eso porque la pared y pegar
pintando y pegando porque hay personas
enojadas porque no encuentran familiares
como
es el tema del feminismo es algo que a
mí yo lo apoyo totalmente yo no veo mal
esa violencia o sal yo no veo mal el que
las mujeres protestan de esa forma
obviamente estoy consciente que eso va a
generar un causó que se generó un caos
pero justo desecados surge el cambio
sabes cuando pasó el tema de la
liberación el ex bético pues tampoco fue
muy bien en forma pacífica también tuvo
que ser de una forma de que la parte
oprimida pues está tan harta que se
libera entonces yo entiendo mucho esas
acciones no creo que hayan sido las
mejores pero quizás no las juzgo porque
yo no sé cómo actuaría o sea yo no sé si
iría a tirar el ángel de la
independencia no sólo a pintarlo si mi
mamá o mi hermana fuera parte de esas
estadísticas a veces creo que ahí cambia
cuando entiendes el porque las personas
están reaccionando a ese punto de
violento el que bebe te digo algo por
ejemplo yo he estado como en estas
situaciones donde a lo mejor me han
podido hacer cosas hoy en día igual no
lo comparto por eso es que por ejemplo
lo que estábamos diciendo de las marchas
yo
siento
que las marchas y son como muy de los
90s cometieron su función sí y como
dicen tuvieron que caminar como en lo
que no estaba pavimentado para que estas
nuevas generaciones incluyéndome
pudiéramos caminar con más tranquilidad
no osea su cometido ya fue pero bueno
qué pasa si seguimos haciendo marchas ya
todo el mundo la toma como una prueba sí
entonces qué es lo que pasa cuando por
ejemplo algo que la de la liberación de
las personas esté de color
hubieron marchas hubieron protestas no
sé que nos que pero sabes que lograron
su cometido en su momento aprobaron
derechos estudiaron se prepararon la
comunidad
ahora es mucha gente que está preparada
que tiene puestos altos y demás yo creo
que eso es lo que deberíamos de hacer en
comunidad por ejemplo gay en la
comunidad de transexuales que
desafortunadamente el mayor campo
laboral para una trans es la
prostitución
el estilismo por ejemplo porque le
pregunto cuando ves a un ajuste de
tragos o a una secretaria trans oa una
abogada trans a pesar de que las aire
donde están las oportunidades para ese
campo laboral entonces yo creo que lo
que sigue ya no son las marchas así es
como prepararnos y es cómo seguir
avanzando yo creo que de esa manera
vamos a impactar más o vamos a lograr
más cuando al final seamos más las que
estemos compitiendo por nuestras
capacidades a puestos altos no por
ejemplo el presidente de eeuu este obama
no es aquel logro que satisfacción y que
admiración para una persona de color
yendo contra todas las especies
estadísticas no empezaría si fuera así
por ejemplo las las feministas o la
comunidad gay no o sea la comunidad
bueno general que dejemos de ver es como
decir lo que a lo mejor si es gay y todo
lo que tú quieras y amas pero como lo
dicen no con los borrachos levanten al
psicólogo borracho es licenciado no así
como lo ves siendo gay
es el doctor y está haciendo maestría en
esto y está haciendo especialidad en
esto ya sabes yo creo que eso es como el
siguiente paso que debemos dar como ya
las marchas es fiesta ya las marchas son
desmadre ya las marchas es como allá ya
viene la marcha no ya libre y textura
comercial sí entiendo tu punto es
sintiendo que quizá la intención de la
marcha como tal ya se cumplió eso es un
hecho porque realmente remontándonos a
la causa o al origen de esa primer
marcha pues fue únicamente la protesta
personas en aquella noche en la que el
bar de eeuu no entonces yo eso veo que
más bien es como una pista de una forma
de conmemorar de
celebrar de cuántos años va desde esa
marcha número uno en la que se liberaron
ya no piensa que a través de la marcha
se donde las personas busquemos la
visibilidad porque la visibilidad como
dices ya la tenemos este tema de que nos
tengamos que seguir preparando pero yo
creo que es muy mal si creo ser parte de
esas personas que están capacitadas y
pueden competir perfectamente contra una
persona heterosexual pero sintiendo que
gran parte quizá de otras comunidades
pues por las pocas posibilidades o por
no sé por las pocas ganas incluso pues
pueden seguir un poco invisibles en los
temas de empresas entonces sintiéndote
punto pero yo no veo nada malo en la en
la marcha sabes by yo creo que la
manzana más es como una forma de
conmemorar de recordar de celebrar
cuantos años llevamos desde aquel día y
se habla así que llevamos pues entiende
que forma parte de esta comunidad no no
porque propiamente uno haya estado en
esta marcha número uno entonces el punto
es sentir como la
empatía está simplemente por ejemplo la
independencia o sea la seguimos
celebrando si la celebración es ponerse
todos bien a gusto y así pero se sigue
conmemorando la independencia de méxico
no pues yo más bien creo que va por
ellos a como
que nuestra fecha histórica desde el
momento en que se liberaron pero no creo
que en la marcha frontal estemos
buscando algo que si nos puede dejar ver
muy mal por todas las conductas que lo
llevan a tener espacio para presionar o
claro claro si es como mi manera mi
manera de ver
se hace muy poco tiempo de hecho éste
está hablando con un grupo de amigos y
me decían por qué le dirías a tus nuevas
generaciones cuál es tu manera de
defender a las nuevas generaciones de tu
comunidad que lo único que dije fue eso
y creo que esta es mi manera de apoyar a
mi comunidad en sus nuevas generaciones
es decir si no estás en un lugar donde
no estás a voz constante
y lucha por lo que tú quieres lucha por
esa independencia y la mayor evidencia
de que si se pueden las cosas puedo
decir que soy una persona que me tomen
como como ejemplo soy una persona
completa mantiene dependiendo de
trabajadora
una persona que le ha costado
claro exactamente entonces eso es mi
manera decirle a mi comunidad está bien
o sea todo va a pasar todo va a ganar y
todos a poner bien perro todos la buena
chingón vamos a dejar en y punta
trabajando
que no se dejen guiar por por personas
personas que ya están donde pudieran
hacer tanto y se enfocan en estancarse
en seguir nada más destrozando se con
que cada quien se preocupe de educar
motivar a sus alrededores a sus entornos
y todos y seamos eso creo que es cuando
ya pasaremos al siguiente punto que es
saber ahora si nos fuimos mil veces
visibles en las organizaciones pues
ahora sí ya podemos que lleguemos a eso
y realmente es mi manera de ver linda tu
comunidad a tu manera porque al final
todos todos estamos con esta lucha tal
vez pero yo creo que su mamá es una
persona admirable una persona que puedes
ver con un respeto que lo puedes ver a
los ojos y decir es buena persona a una
persona que
y al final ese es la misma loca que todo
mundo espera
yo también con leo yo también hecho
desmadre llosa pero también hay momentos
se fundían
exactamente entonces por ejemplo aquí en
el fraccionamiento donde estoy
creo que me ganado como ese papel de ser
una persona responsable
entonces
[Música]
lo que es manera de
cambiar la visión que tienen de nosotros
yo creo que en las que la introspección
como deforme la que yo ayudo pensar
rabil de estos episodios justo como el
tratar de empoderar a la gente de
decirle todo esto te puede pasar pero si
se puede saber es por qué he visto que
muchas veces eso es una excusa porque si
se puede o sea si te duele y sí pero
aguanta sabes o sea la gente que ya
estamos hechas para alentar
o sea como puede estar entre ambientes
de puros hombres hetero ambientes super
desinformados y aún así yo estaba en mi
empresa e hice una pues hay mi
aportación y ahorita no estoy ahí porque
pues decidí ahora hacer lo que en verdad
me apasiona pero es eso o sea él no nos
sentir que es una limitante quizá a un
punto menos para poder estar a la altura
de cualquier personaje pero
este súper importante y te voy a decir
porque esto que tú mencionas de que los
grises están como para aguantar es que
es ahora cagado pero
decir que es cierto que las personas
gays nacimos para ser libres nacimos
para ser auténticos nacimos para ir en
contra de todo y al final el hablar de
decir ir en contra de todo realmente es
todo llámese familia llámese 2 a todos
porque incluso muchas veces tu precio a
pagar es la soledad es el desprecio
muchas veces ha sido humillación o sea
han sido cosas fuertes pero dime quién
en su sano juicio
permite esas cosas cuantos
heterosexuales los permiten cuantos
centros sexuales aguantarían esas cosas
con tal de ir por tú por tu autenticidad
con tal de ir por tu por tus sueños por
tu manera de vivir por tu por dignificar
tu manera de vivir de responder porque
te voy a preguntar
a ti que te dicen pero a escondidas pero
no digas que esto es como tener el valor
de decir de reconocer que te atrae una
persona trans no creas que el ser muy
hombrecito es andar por ahí violentando
o sea no justamente demuestra que tú a
los que creen que el ser hombre es
violento agresivos o sean ojalá tengan
el valor de reconocer cuando una mujer
trans o una persona trans incluso un
hombre gay después de parecer atractivos
al menos para una noche y te puede decir
que por ejemplo no me ha tocado este
hombre que me quiera presumir o por
ejemplo
en este momento no estoy buscando
parejas la verdad entonces yo también
que soy como que apenas tuvo una
relación fugaz con un niño de la ciudad
de mexico de hecho era todo lo contrario
a lo que yo quería
prácticamente me dijo que era mucho para
ella
como un hombre no tolera la idea de
haber preparado a una mujer asegura él
sigue bien inyecta esa forma que tiene
que depender del don de hecho fue un
gran un gran tema entre él y yo porque
él llegó a mi vida cuando pase con una
situación como de tipo crisis y yo pues
no estoy pidiendo o sea relax yo veo que
ayudó como lo hago no porque dije no te
quiero o sea si no será como el cráter o
preciosa no quiero que cobre a sus
necesidad de ir a las necesidades
emocionales las estás cubriendo bien y
me gusta y por sutil estar contigo deja
que yo cobra lo demás y eso era algo que
le afectaba mucho porque él es un ser
con un cuidador entonces eso fue lo que
al final me dijo eso le estaba
acomodando en su ego no como en su
masculinidad
y me ha pasado varias veces eso sabes
que proteger y
que planean ser como los de la energía
fuerte de los que prácticamente la trans
en la vestida o el
travesti lado el game bueno
prácticamente se ponen de suponer de de
tapete para que me usen se limpian y se
vayan y pues yo no sea yo
el muro de berlín y
entonces por eso es que terminan yéndose
o sea eso sí es una realidad y te digo
algo hasta la fecha es cuestión sexual
no ha habido alguien así que te diga yo
me he hecho explotar sin necesidad de
hacerme cosa por eso tiene que ser como
un tema muy muy complicado en en los
hombres sé que es difícil para ellos
afrontarse como llevando una vida y
fíjate que lo puedo relacionar al
travestismo porque por ejemplo han
llevado a lo mejor una vida hetero que
yo lo puedo anclar como al llevar una
vida gay al momento de salir del closet
con una mujer trans es como el llevo una
vida no sé si estoy preparado para que
la gente me juzgue de esta manera o
verme yo con una mujer trans a saber al
decirlo yo estoy como en una vida gay no
sé si estoy preparado para verme como en
una vida trans soy una persona muy
fuerte es una persona muy resiliente soy
una persona que generó independencia
absolutamente en todo incluso está en lo
sexual con juguetes y demás el primer
orgasmo que he tenido me lo regale yo
sabes
comparto lo que dice ser no es alguien a
los hombres no son una necesidad
neurólogo entonces es como ellos no
puede satisfacer sí exacto está todo o
sea yo que si esta maravilla entonces no
vital y quizás ese resultado fue cuando
dije gracias a ese momento empezó a
generar dependencia sexual pues no nos
dejáis chinguen a su madre yo no tengo
necesidad de contarle un sabes
pero cuando y cuando cuando cuando éste
no pues ya valió madre esto porque pues
siente ser adiós inalcanzable
ahorita es grave
[Música]
si estoy contigo es porque me gustas
porque a lo mejor te más de sabroso pero
eso no quiere decir que me voy a aclarar
tus sentimientos ni a ti ni exactamente
nada más hacemos la cochinada y te vas
y ya hablamos es para la misma necesito
digo yo llevo como cinco o seis y muchas
de eso me dice como weiss pues pensando
tus mejores años para hacer cosas así
sin hacer cosas así
esperes que eso es un tabú vos a la
sexualidad shoppings que la vida es la
experimenta solo sabes o la puedes vivir
tu sólo entonces el creerse debe estar
en una relación para disfrutar la
sexualidad lo que también es un error te
genera esa dependencia pasaron las cosas
diferentes porque vuelvo a lo mismo con
todo el aprendizaje con tal experiencia
con toda la trayectoria pues si tuve
mucho aprendizaje
entonces dije estaba yo elijo no
sabotear esta relación estaba yo elijo
hacer las cosas completamente diferentes
cuando yo formalizado tuvimos muy buena
comunicación tuvimos muy buen
entendimiento y sobre el motivo
y lo vi a los ojos y le dije neta perdón
perdóname voy a hacer las cosas bien
contigo y tengo que hacer una pregunta
en él si quieres ser mi novio
y luego él me dice yo te tengo que hacer
otra pregunta tienes vagina
y es servín obvia y ya si ve que
llorando los dos y demás sabrosa es que
entonces aprendizaje también en
elegir ver a las personas ya como
maestros de vida y no como verdugos
entonces si hoy en día por ejemplo
poniendo como ya en una balanza la
relación tipo decir que fue una relación
bonita aunque fue fugaz y demás fue una
relación bonita una relación donde el
vino a enseñar más cosas pero sobre todo
me vino a reafirmar quién soy yo como
persona quién soy yo como pareja en qué
lugar está mi lealtad y todo lo que
puedo ofrecer o sea yo lo presume de que
en redes sociales espante a todo mi
ganado con eso te digo todo
ya mí me vale ahora yo estaba muy feliz
estábamos estrecha y demás entonces
cuando hice todo eso que quede como
pende no porque al final yo mandándoles
de ola desaparecido a los jóvenes y los
gays mandan al archivo pero digo bueno
por alguna razón pero vuelvo a lo mismo
no me arrepiento porque soy te dejo
cosas e hizo a darle cuenta en donde
estaba y hacia donde quiero llegar con
alguien y todo lo que esté dispuesta a
hacer por alguien y a dar creo que eso
es una buena forma de ver las vivencias
sean buenas malas afortunadas no tan
afortunadas como que puedo aprender de
aquí que me llevo de esta experiencia
y me gusta mucho cómo piensas o si estás
pensando qué es lo que más te conviene
cuál es la forma en la que tú podrás
estar más seguro segura
sacarte bien feliz como eres y eso está
padre eso creo que es para digno de
ponerlo como ejemplo y
entonces cómo te reconoces de yo algo
esto yo soy esto creo que es algo muy
válido y que todos tenemos que hacer
todos tenemos que abrazar esa parte de
yo me reconozco por esto yo valgo esto
el correcto de esta parte en la que
dices no como el hecho de abrazarnos
realmente desde hace cuántos no te
abrazas no se deshace en cuanto lo que
dices cosas bonitas esto es cuando yo
mayor consciente de eso creo que fue
donde empezaron a cambiar las cosas
porque pues en mí solamente había juicio
y yo era como juzgaba muy feo todo ha
sido un proceso ahora porque hoy en día
lo mejor expert habilidad y gracias a
dios gracias a mi esfuerzo gracias a mi
valentía hoy tengo y me ha costado mucho
visita una persona con trastornos
alimenticios por ejemplo si fuimos al
filme cortaba güeyos había un jinete que
los dos os dar la quitina personas con
depresión es fuerte tal vez una persona
que esté pensó en el suicidio entonces
eso tampoco quiere decir que si en esos
momentos pues estás pasando por algún
tema parecido no quiere decir que no
puedas llegar en un momento estar feliz
y amarte
va a ser un proceso largo pero si se
puede ir te vas a armar y te vas a
querer y te vas a querer bonito y te vas
a dar cuenta que el mayor amor a hacer
para usted es básicamente el amor o de
llegar aquí y no me refiero como el tema
de pareja igual lo mejor sino en estos
momentos les echo wright a que se vaya
pero hoy en día tipo decir que soy una
persona bendecida armada por por mi
familia por mis sobrinos que me
llenan el alma por mis hermanos pero mi
fan por mi mamá por mis amigos por por
el trabajo por mis clientas por el elche
el cómo les trabajo el agradecimiento
los detalles que tienen conmigo
y puedo y lo único que podría decir hoy
en día a mi yo presente es gracia no
gracias por todo lo que fuiste gracias
por todo lo que eres y gracias por todo
lo que sea creo que eso es como en como
mi mi resumen a 27 años gracias gracias
por aguantar
y gracias por esforzarte también no
entonces por descargar 90 conclusiones y
eso creo que es la cndh el punto el
cáncer amables con nosotros
muchas veces creo que permitimos o nos
preocupa más la otra persona porque oye
te digo yo también tabla horita así que
sin móvil muy estable muy 7 años soltero
pero o se pregunta en el inicio se puede
el punto es que quieras y que noten
victimice es grandote ahí en ya no puedo
hacer nada pues te quiera es ciertamente
mucho me case increíble en por algo todo
esto nos encontramos de la forma que
están contados
mira yo creo que él obviamente no vas a
conocer a una persona en ese tiempo no
pero mira así en este momento mi
historia mi conversación mi energía a mí
mi voluntad mi amor te sirve de algo le
sirve de algo a esto escuchando tómenlo
no trance
acéptenlo y en verdad lo único que puedo
decirles es que deseo que toda la
felicidad llega a ustedes en esta
tranquilidad de la emocionalidad que
despierta el amor si este estado cerrado
si este estado dormido y que lesione
dirección en la vida pero que es como lo
único que puedo desear para ustedes
muchas gracias a mí me agradó mucho que
está contigo dijiste cosas muy bonitas
que espero que hasta bailaron le pueden
llegar a más personas en efecto me
agrada la idea
iguales
pues muchas gracias por la invitación
[Risas]
[Música]
y hasta aquí el episodio para el día de
hoy
después de esta enriquecedora
conversación que se tuvo con romina
espero que quede una visión más amplia
sobre las diferentes formas y las
diferentes posibilidades en que se puede
experimentar vivir o identificar el
travestismo como una identidad muchas
veces éste no querer hacer la transición
no es por un tema de no sentirlo en tu
interior sino que únicamente el
detenerte a pensar si en verdad estás
lista listo o lista para vivir con esa
adecuación corporal en el día a día
déjenme saber sus comentarios dudas
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
las encuentran como rob el podcast del
eje del té q voy a adicionar un link en
la descripción del episodio para que
puedan llegar a cada una de ellas se
pueden quedar online y compartir con
suscribirse en youtube a ayudar mucho
para que toda esta información pueda
llegar a más personas y de esta manera
nos encaminemos a hacer esa sociedad que
vive incluye respeta y es empática con
la diversidad no me queda más que
recordarles que mi nombre es oscar olmos
así que nos escuchamos en el próximo
episodio para continuar construyendo
conocimiento derribando prejuicios
[Aplausos]